who Thrive and succeed because they're a
man because life is easy therefore I'd
be like I would expect you okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you an example my
dad's the half top half a percentage of
earners okay he he's the white man right
that but but here's the thing he worked
80 hours a week my whole life I didn't I
didn't get to see him yeah how how is
that like the patriarchy when my dad put
in 80 hours every week his whole life
from the time I was like a child right
missed a lot a lot of a lot of [ __ ] like
he earned that yeah and I'm never gonna
say that's like no the patriarchy anyway
but now now he's a white male CEO yeah
right so is is that the patriarchy or
did women not choose to do that well
that's the only way we could argue is
the only defendants dolls that you could
have is if you had a exact female
replica to be like she likely would not
get where he is that's the only way we
could argue it right but it doesn't want
to take away from his efforts it doesn't
take away so then why do we why do we
talk about it at all if you can't if you
have no no idea why there's a pay Gap
yeah yeah like like it's is it possible
that it's the the industries that women
pick because if you if you yeah that
have more choice so if you go to like
the most egalitarian countries there's
more of a pay Gap rather than less
because women choose jobs with people
and then use jobs with objects so like
my I'm I'm from a family of ten all the
boys are Engineers none of the girls are
Engineers like is it possible it's a
biological difference rather than a
patriarchy yeah no I think I think well
I think the pay Gap is more like within
so I don't know if you saw on
International women's day they had a bot
that literally showed you the pay Gap
within organizations so obviously women
will tend to go for things like being a
nurse being a teacher yeah they pay a
lot less than being yeah
yes but the pay Gap then exists in so a
lot of things where there's a lot of
male actors who will be like I will not
sign on to this contract unless I know
my female counterparts are being paid
the same and so I think the pay Gap then
comes and well it's also the tree it's
also the trait like disagreeableness so
as women like we're naturally more
agreeable 100 so so we're I'm more I'm
terrible at negotiating I just want to
make everyone happy and I just want to
be like yeah I'll do whatever for
nothing and
um and but that's like men are more just
agreeable if you look at the
agreeability scale does that make sense
yeah yeah so again like why do we just
assume patriarchy when you don't know if
it's because of different personality
traits and gender differences no and
gender they are so real so in my studies
um it showed that so men are more likely
to go for so let's say there's a job and
a woman is more likely to look at a job
specification and go oh but she's more
likely to say no to herself and she's
more likely to go
um or I don't know if I'm good enough
yeah or as a man is more likely to
actually inflate their ability and be
like I'm gonna go for that and it
actually reflects in relationships where
a man is more likely to actually shoot
above and be like yeah I can I can yes
so it's a reason we see a lot of um
less attractive men with more attractive
women the women are more likely to be
like look I spent a lot of my life being
like I'm a four out of 10. I'm I'm
probably about seven but I spent a lot
of my life dating men and people would
be like Amy that guy is not in your
league like why do you not and they're
like they're definitely like you know
out like you're out of their league and
it's actually yeah there's a real gender
difference and
is that biological is it social
um right there that's because men and
men and women value different things man
value looks more women don't value looks
as much they value things like social
status like a blue check mark a blue and
this is yeah I've dated a guy with a
blue check mark right like we like
social status yeah like we'd be lying if
we said we didn't care or whatever it is
like it's it could be height right it
could be like it could be you know maybe
he's not as good looking facially but
he's he makes money yeah or he makes
money yeah right and so that's why we
see there's a gap in that yeah yeah we
don't we don't scream patriarchy for
like men yeah yeah like but then we
don't know that's it we don't know is it
because of uh so you've got the
biopsychosocial approach
um which is what I tend to um subscribe
to because that's it it's not easy to be
like oh it's just biology or it's just
sociology or it's just your personal my
question is like yeah I just don't even
understand like in this day and age how
we are fighting the patriarchy like what
more can they do I can do any job I want
like nothing has ever stopped me from
doing anything yeah so like I don't even
know what's wrong like I don't even know
what I need feminism for now okay I
can't think of one thing
um I have a question going back to what
you said and I think it's fun but I
wanna
give you a scenario so you said
originally that the reason you arguably
apply a higher standard to men is
because you felt life was easier for
them so it's easy you should expect more
from them or they have advanced is
right let more so than women right so my
question then
is would you apply a higher standard to
a white woman
over for example a black male
you would
really
so you would expect the white women to
earn a certain amount to be taller than
you
to make you feel protected and to be
able to provide for you more so than if
you were getting to know a blackmail
I well then it's the intersection
between race and gender but that's it as
a westernized white woman I'm well aware
of my privilege
um and it's like I know that
like ah it depends on well that's it it
depends on
oh it's tough because I'll be I'll be
honest like I think women just always
apply a higher standard to men than
women because they're men regardless of
what race they are so say like we go for
a job interview oh wait wait you're not
in binary me and him yeah who are you
dating
[Applause]
who are you picking yeah he probably
makes more money than me yeah but then
but then but then being a female I'd
probably be like is money my most
important or is it emotional connection
and how funny you are like it would
depend on what as a woman I think I
would oh I don't know
that's it would would well as a woman
that doesn't necessarily want kids
anytime soon and it's quite financially
independent I probably wouldn't be like
money probably wouldn't be my priority
so then I'd be like Well Physical
attractive would come into it but then
funny okay
no but it's really hard it's really hard
no but it's really hard to be like is it
just money is it protection because I'm
also quite Scrappy so I can hold my own
as well I don't want a man to protect me
because I'm like I'll fight do you think
you could fight me yeah do you think you
could beat me in a fight yeah because
I'll just go straight for the eyes
straight for the eyes and you are
disabled yeah I will I will let you
believe that that's it that's if you're
trying to fight me and I blind you in
one eye you're not gonna hurt you you're
not gonna I'm like not even okay you can
blind him in one iron he'll knock you
out
if someone's eyes I think that's a very
nice I'm not allowed to hit women so
okay this is a very nice that's a
double-sanded hit a woman hit me thank
you I think if a girl hits a man he can
knock her out he can knock her out yeah
you can yeah
fellas don't do it it's not worth it you
know you're gonna get double the jail
time it's not worth it but then again
that's double stand because then other
men will start to hit you and be like
you hit a woman no no if she started on
you you've got every right every right I
would say if my life is threatened then
fine but if if my life isn't threatened
I'll grapple her but I won't I won't
punch her in the throat I think the
majority of girls will hit a guy if push
comes to shelf because they believe that
one they're protected and two they're
okay oh did you know did you know
statistically in terms of the the line
of crossing over to physical abuse women
cross that line more
statistically speaking I would believe
that but it's actually but all it is is
that when men cross the line
manner when naturally more aggressive
and violent so when men crossed as many
of you know you know just ban
talk
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible